from the Hollywood heavy hitters to the
groundbreaking innovators to the
stunning Dark Horse surprises the early
days of 2018 saw no small number of
fantastic films hit the box-office
luckily for all the sinner files out
there it seems like the summer which is
traditionally a benchmark season for
Studios to release big pictures has
managed to more than live up to the hype
here are a few of the seasons very best
movies hereditary hereditary drew
enormous buzz in the months leading up
to its release its debut at Sundance in
January 2018 was greeted with
overwhelming praise with much of it
lavished on the performance of Toni
Collette and while many festival
favorites struggled to find their place
among general audiences hereditary
followed through with ease this
audacious feature debuted for
writer-director ari Astor shaped up to
be a significant box-office success
supplemented by an array of shining
reviews the general consensus among
critics has been that Colette has
delivered the performance of her career
meanwhile the film's underlying themes
of menacing family dynamics and the
passing down of tragedy through the
generations helps hereditary get under
your skin and stay there New Yorker
critic Anthony Lane warns I would
hesitate to recommend it to the readily
traumatized for viewers recuperating
from a wounded childhood or from a
festering relationship it could scrape
too close to the bone ant-man
and the wasp no surprise here with
ant-man and the wasp Marvel Studios
landed their third smash hit of the year
and their 20th straight film to debut at
number one
audiences were in desperate need of a
palate cleanser after Avengers infinity
war and returning director Peyton Reed
gave them one as well as a worthy sequel
to 2015's ant-man
it's fleeter on its feet more assured
and perhaps even funnier than the
original hiya Jeff how was school today
film fare calm went so far as to call it
the funniest Marvel film you'll see
which is high praise indeed considering
that thor ragnarok was released less
than a year earlier the film's tone is
loose and playful while the action
sequences are confidently and
competently staged the stakes are
suitably low enough to making ant-man
and the wasp a much-needed breath of
fresh air after the sheer trauma that
was infinity war Mission Impossible
fallout for over two decades
Tom Cruise's put himself in mortal
danger for the amusement of audiences
via the surprisingly resilient mission
impossible franchise which has failed to
lose even an iota of momentum despite
its Stars advancing age now in his 50s
Cruz continues to insist on doing every
stunt that it's physically possible for
him to do which is no short order for a
series which has long favored top-shelf
action set-pieces / plot and
characterization
director christopher mcquarrie became
the series first returning director
remaining in the seat previously held by
directors like Brad Bird John Woo and JJ
Abrams this steady hand behind the
camera as well as Cruz's otherworldly
dedication to the role of eternally put
upon IMF agent Ethan Hunt resulted in a
crackerjack picture which pulled in some
of the best reviews of the entire series
as impossible as it might seem this
venerable action series and its star
just seemed to keep getting better with
age or as the Detroit News puts it bless
this franchise we're truly not worthy
black Klansmen with a new generation of
stunningly talented African American
filmmakers finally getting their place
in the spotlight it's easy to forget
Spike Lee nearly 30 years after
detonating a cinematic nuclear bomb with
1989's do the right thing Lee has
returned to form with black Klansmen a
hilarious scathing insightful piece that
critics have praised near uniformly has
his best picture in years
John David Washington stars as a black
police detective in the 1970s who with
the aid of a Jewish fellow officer
played by Adam driver tries to
infiltrate the Ku Klux Klan critics were
roundly amazed by Lee's mastery of tone
as he abused dramatic high-stakes
situations with his singular Sensibility
Digital spy's Hugh Armitage summed up
this consensus neatly calling the film a
roller coaster that is laugh-out-loud
winning isn't shocking you into stunned
silence a damn fine and funny piece of
entertainment and a testament to Lee's
skills as an artist crazy rich Asians
directed by Jon M Chu crazy rich Asians
features Constance Wu leading a nearly
all Asian cast to tell the story of a
native New Yorker who accompanies her
boyfriend to a wedding in Singapore soon
after its release it became a surprise
critical smash with all the trappings of
a genuine cultural phenomenon reviewer
Randy Jones encapsulated the critics
consensus by concluding that crazy rich
Asians takes familiar tropes
and revitalizes them and its entire
genre a great cast amazing direction and
powerful writing
like black panther before it crazy rich
Asians constitutes a clear message to
Hollywood execs that heartfelt well
executed stories featuring people of
color can not only cross cultural
boundaries but smash them and earn huge
box office returns in the process